in march 2020 the kovid 19 outbreak was
declared a pandemic kovid 19 can be
characterized as a pandemic since then
there have been more than 400 million
recorded cases and nearly 6 million
deaths worldwide experts say kovid is
unlikely to be eradicated and instead we
can expect it to become endemic so what
does that mean
[Music]
the key difference between a pandemic
and an endemic is the speed it spreads
in a pandemic we see exponential growth
across large geographical areas disease
spreads rapidly from country to country
and often across continents
covered 19 for instance originated in
china and spread around the world
epidemics also spread rapidly but within
a specific geographical area endemic
disease spreads more consistently and
predictably for covid19 to become
endemic cases would have to be
relatively low and constant but the key
point is the virus can't be eliminated
it will be with us for the long term
if covid19 does become endemic cases
will be lower but it doesn't mean that
symptoms will be milder a good example
of an endemic but often fatal disease is
malaria
[Music]
given the recent surge in omicron cases
and the unpredictability of new variants
the transition to an endemic is probably
pretty far off the spread of the virus
relies on the ability to infect a high
number of susceptible people the point
at which this is no longer possible
signals a shift to an endemic but this
is hard to predict
however with a high percentage of the uk
population now vaccinated it is a
positive move in the right direction
[Music]
if and when covid19 becomes endemic the
government will be able to review
remaining restrictions aimed at slowing
the spread of the disease it is my
expectation that we will be able to end
the last domestic restrictions including
the legal requirement to self-isolate if
you test positive a full month early
boris johnson says he will present a
strategy for living with kovid on the
21st of february
as the reliance on immunity increases we
can expect to see a larger focus on
global vaccination rates the who
originally set a target to vaccinate 40
percent of every population in the world
by the end of 2021. the current target
is 70
by mid 2022 as part of their pandemic
exit strategy but the who says the world
is still a long way off describing kovid
as endemic it is still a pandemic and
the who says it's still an acute
emergency and the worry is that a new
variant could throw us a curveball
causing severe disease and evading
vaccines that would put us right back
[Music]
you